ああああああ
さて皆さん
家族所有をご存じでしょう
日本の弁当系の一つ
保存さという方
歌舞伎のイメージはいかがでしょうか
難しい
言ってることがよくわからん
面白くないん
秘密めいどぞ
などそういう言葉を聞くと僕はそんなことはないんだ
歌舞伎こんなに面白いんだって何十分もかけて思いっきり
熱弁したくなるんですが
今日はそのようなつまりきっぱここはかな
まず今僕が
歌舞伎をえんじゅう
物心ついた頃から
歌舞伎があります
いわゆる梨園の世界に生まれました
僕は
幼い頃から今日までずっと
歌舞伎を演じることが好きです
好きなことを仕事ができる
これはとても幸せなことだと思います
しかし
ちょうど大学に入りそうでしょうか
好きなだけでこの仕事を続けていけるのだろうか
一生演じテープがでも楽しいと可能性が
この歌舞伎にはあるのだろうか
不安を感じました
その時大学で出会ったある友達は
未来の美女をかけて
自分でせろから自由
自分の将来を3名
その仕方がその時の僕には何か
可能性に満ちていて凄くかっこよく見えたんですね
大学という環境の中で周囲が自由な選択をしてい
将来の夢を楽しい
それに憧れていたのかもしれません
僕もう一同
今までも一緒して去っていっ
歌舞伎を考えてみたら
もっと相撲以上に楽しむことができるんじゃないか
これが続けていくこのたちも続けていく理由を
見つけることができないできるんじゃないかと
突拍子もなくとか思ったんです
そこでいま自分が容易ている
歌舞伎の世界の過去にも
目指すことにしました
と大きなことを言っているんですけれど
しわー
あまのじゃくでそれでも歌舞伎には400名という長い歴史があります
そしてアマダの先輩たちが積み重ねてきた
市税があります僕一人が何かアクションを起こしたところでそう簡単に変わるわけでは
ないだろうと思っている自分も
お前に
確認をしたもたくさんのつまり事があります
使われる言葉はほとんどが
邪淫で批評が昔言葉ですし
ゲイバー先輩たちから継承され英語文を縛りがたくさんあります
一方の思うばマミ大抵のものではい
一瞬で崩せるはずがない
それは
日ができます
相手は
長い年月に閉じこもった
も気が合っ
どうしようか
僕に今何ができるのだろう
いくらがいても
そこには必ず
決まり事による壁があります
そこには崩せない限界があったのです
僕が歌舞伎をよって何か違うぞをしない限り
02われ
でも僕は歌舞伎が好きだから
歌舞伎と暖簾を切ることもです
思い悩むだった
それ崎神獣という作品の広い
遊女の19歳の初というえお
自分の同じ年で19歳で演じることになります
このそれだけ神獣どういう作品かというと
歴史上の有名子近松門左衛門が約300年前に作った名作で僕の祖父がその後発動やを
1100回以上を維持している
重みのある作品で人生初の主役
この作品を演じることは田中とか周りの人たちもいました
あの人間5坂田藤十郎の孫なんだから何かしてくれるだろう
良いそちらた中村傘のが見れるそうめっ
様々な重み
プレッシャーがのしかかってきます
そんな僕に祖父は
一つだけ
アドバイスとして
自分のお初をつける
のお初
この時僕は一つの挑戦をすることにしません
今までとスタンスを変えて伝統を敵と思って戦っていくのではなく
歌舞伎の胸を張ってその中で上がっていっ
そして
どれだけ自分が人中
その囲いの中で僕は楽しむことができる
自分の髪を作るためにはマジうっ
その作品相手を知らなくてはなりません
そこで調整の一つとして僕はそれだけ真鍮という作品に対して自分が思っている
疑問なぜたくさん問いかけることにしました
なぜしか閥門際もこの作品を作ったんだろうか
まずこれはが武器なんだろう
根本的なことからなぜこの始まり方をするんだろう
なぜこのシーンでこの音楽が使われるのだろうかという技術的なこと
そして究極弾なぜ今僕が
歌舞伎をこの作品を選ん神宮
これらのなぜを問いかけて研究して答えを出して地域知識を増やすことでこの作品に
詰まった
回打っ政治をお客さんに伝えるこれこそが楽しみへの糸口だと思っていましたが
これ答えは病院は出ませんでした
というよりむしろ
メイク fuck 体などが曖昧なものです
結局
答えが出ないまま
の舞台を支えてしまいいい
毎日今日も
次ておきました
しかし
本番をされている開き僕は
目には見えない言葉にもできない
なるかを感じたんですそのないかというのは
僕が見せ場で決めジェリーこういった理
何かポーズをとってしまったりすると客席の後方から
大向こうとって a
ありこばや感性がすると客席に拍手あっ
そして感じる
心地の曜日
そのときは何が何だか全く分かりませんでしょ
この感覚は何なんだろう
後々冷静に考えてみるとそれを言葉にすることができました
それは
舞台空間が生まれる
まあ
この場というものこそ歌舞伎という制限の中で
僕の自由な楽しいを作る穴バイブしてくれるパートナー
相棒なぁ
まあ
不対応
パフォーマーが一方的に皆さんに営業をするだけではありません
パフォーマーは演技に対して観客は拍手や声援で労働的に働き掛けをしてくれる
このキャッチボールドレンサーガ
バボ生み出します
僕の大好きな大切なパートナーである馬は
一人の力
1本2校では生まれません
もう皆さんは今お気づきだと思います
この01点を解消にも
アブ
まだ前のいるがと思うんです
だから僕もこうやって楽しくスピーチはでき
ここには水カーでは木刀そして長袖である
皆さんだけが味わえ感じることができる
ここにしかない
世界が人間味のある世界は作られているんです
そして株
僕も皆さんもこのたい点も c
僕は間が空きらとこうやって
姿勢を入れます
限られた空間だからこそあり勝ち
これは必ず存在すると思います
その価値を
好きになる活用し
自分の楽しいを作り出す
そしてそこにしかない狡猾デー
自分の宝物をお話します
限られた空間は本当に素晴らしいものです
これ仕事じゃないんですけどね
日本代表の試合勘ん
同意しておりますサポーターと一緒に大いに盛り上がって勝利したら喜びお渡し会
負けたら可能
市議をみんなで共有する
これは
サブ缶ビール片手に一人でテレビのまえば
はいないと思います
僕は構成
歌舞伎という囲いの中にあるばを通して
囲われた空間の中で楽しむことに成功しましたん
今日皆さんに僕は何を伝えたいですか
制限を感じた時
すべてを知って
どこかに答えに乗ってます
囲われ彼の顔を詰めなおすことで
そこにしかない
そこにしかできないん
楽しみスペシャルが楽しいが存在するということ
加工あれば歌舞伎の世界しかしそこから逃げることなく
僕は
自分の歯のシーンをそこにしかない甲府を見つけることができました
そして一生続けていく
魏延を探したことができません
今は何でもできてしまうしたいだからこそ
何をしていいのかわからないです
もしあの時他の選択肢を撮っていたら
全く違う人生がもっと素晴らしい人生が待っていたかもしれません
でも僕は
その時自分が置かれた環境を信じました
皆さんにとっての
過去には何でしょうか
文が入っている囲いを見つめろ c
が速くすることで
自分に合った楽しいを見つけることができるのではないでしょうか
それこそが制限の中にある
自由ほしい
ただしバー
探しん
楽しいバー
そこにある
ロスコしょん
それだけ新中の19歳を発
23歳の僕も演じレバー今年82歳になる
pop も演じています
僕は一緒この歌舞伎所為か声の中で様々な楽しみを生み出していくことを誓います
ありがとうございますはぁ
ああああああ